(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] Have a seat!
I love this dress.
- I'm so hungover.
(Kelly laughs)
I am so hungover.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, that's the worst.
- Oh my gosh.
- I always walk in...
I love when I walk in and
Glo, my makeup artist...
I'm like, I'm sorry.
- My face looks drained.
- You've got a lot of work
to do.
- Yeah, you're gonna
earn that money today.
- I need the stuff,
you know, that you fill in the walls with,
you call it Polyfilla here.
You know, if there's a hole in the wall,
and you try and make it look better?
I need a lot of that
packed into my face today.
- Yes.
- I'm feeling that.
- Well, thank you for being here, that's-
- I'm here 'cause it's you.
- Oh gosh, I love you.
(audience cheers)
Well, welcome back to the show.
And it's summertime now.
So what do you do for summer?
Do you go on holiday?
Do you do anything fun?
- Well I try to, because obviously...
I don't know when you guys
have your school holidays
but ours are like end of July
until the beginning of September, so-
- Oh, it's shorter.
- Yeah, ours is then.
- Really glad I'm American right now.
- Yes.
(Kelly laughs)
Because that's our window of sun.
We're like...
- Oh!
(Kelly laughs)
That's amazing.
I didn't think about that.
- Where did you go?
Did you ever do anything fun?
Did you like family trips growing up?
- Well, yes we did actually.
My mom's an opera singer
or was before she retired.
So we would go on her opera tour with her.
- That's incredible.
- Which is just not normal.
Yeah, incredible.
Yeah, the first knowledge I had of America
was like Austin and New Orleans,
and San Antonio.
Yeah.
- Your first entrance
to America was Texas.
That's awesome.
- Yeah.
- It's very different.
- Yeah, but also like,
because she was singing, you know,
the Metropolitan Opera House in New York.
And so that was my first little thing,
you know, obviously being a singer,
I was like...
- Wow.
- It's just magic, yeah.
Sitting in the orchestra.
- I've been there.
- So my holidays were not normal.
You know, it wasn't like
just going on a beach.
- Is that when you kind
of figured out like,
I wanna be a singer as well?
- I think so.
I mean, what were you...
People asked me that and I'm like,
I don't remember wanting
to do anything else.
And when I heard that
people had grown up jobs,
I remember thinking, "They... They what?"
- Why would you do that?
- Yeah.
Why would you not just
sing, dance and act?
I honestly couldn't compute it.
- I love that.
What an amazing childhood.
I remember going...
I'm the opposite.
I was brought up where
you just had real jobs.
And then I was like, "Wait,
you can make money doing that?"
You know, I was just like, "Wait, what?"
Yeah, I thought that was-
- Yeah, I think 'cause
of my mom's influence,
I don't think they were surprised
when I wanted nothing to do
with a grown-up profession.
- Like a cubicle?
- Yeah.
- Well our daughters
are about the same age.
Does she get to travel with you?
'Cause you get to travel so much.
- Yes, but I'm finding now that she's...
I find it really inconvenient
that she's at school.
I want her to come out and play with me.
- Mine finds it inconvenient, too.
She wants to go with me.
- Yeah, they've got to that age
where you kind of have to respect
their education, you know?
Which is a bit difficult,
but I'm gonna try and bring her a bit more
and maybe bring a tutor or something.
Because coming to things
like this, for her to see...
Our girlies, seeing us working
and how important it is.
- That's an education.
- Yeah, that women are just like,
"I'm getting out there."
- So I agree with that too.
Obviously, we love school too.
- We love school.
Very important.
- So wait, does she know...
When you were traveling,
does she know that her mom
once got kicked out of a hotel?
- I don't know what you're talking about.
So, look....
Look, can I just say that
if you're going to leave a
hostess trolley in a corridor
when people have had a
little beverage or two-
- You're inviting trouble.
- Right, you are inviting trouble.
So I lay on top of it,
my friend lay through it,
and another friend of ours
pushed us down the corridor,
and we accidentally smacked into this...
You know, when the wheels are like
(imitating wheels clacking)
Smacked into this thing and
this woman opens the door
and goes, "Well, thank you very much!
I just got my baby to sleep!"
And we had to go
downstairs and sign a thing
saying we'd never come back to the hotel.
- You're so cool!
Here's my thing.
I heard this story and I was like,
that got you kicked out?
- Yes!
- Do you know what kinds
of things I have seen
and heard on tour?
Like, I can't even...
I was like, wow.
A lot of people I know would've....
Would've been kicked out.
- They were not happy.
And I actually thought they were...
'Cause I was there to do all my fittings
for "Spamalot" on Broadway.
And I thought, "Oh, my god.
They're gonna think I'm
an English reprobate."
- They'll think you're fun!
- Honestly, yeah, not good.
(audience applauding)
- The season finale of "Ted
Lasso" is about to happen.
And I've heard it might be the end-end.
Is it the end-end?
- Well, I don't know.
I mean, Jason says it's the
end of that three-season arc.
- Oh, interesting.
- Yeah, I mean, I feel like trapping him
in a dungeon with a notepad and a pen.
- That's a good idea.
- And just going,
"Dude, what are you doing?"
You can't step away from it.
The characters are so
beloved and we all love it.
I mean, I would play her when
her teeth are falling out
in a retirement home sitting outside it
with mud splashing her, you know?
I just want to see her through.
I love her so much.
- I love the idea that though.
Of almost taking a show and
doing it in different...
Like, almost how they do with Marvel,
you know what I'm saying?
You'd see different characters
and different things.
That's a cool idea.
Y'all should do that, Jason.
- I know, Jason.
Where's the camera?
Jason.
- I love that you do an
American for "Jason."
- Jason!
- Okay, so on the show,
Ted brings you the biscuits, right?
- Yes.
- So, okay, you say the actual cookie
isn't actually that good right?
- They weren't.
Season one, they were
absolutely revolting.
You know, like a ceiling
tile in a bathroom?
It was like...
Like making all your saliva disappear.
But they also didn't know
that I was gonna go at
them like a crazy loon.
Like (imitates devouring food).
Because I wanted it to be
like her emotional support.
Like a crutch.
- Emotional eating?
I don't know what you're referring to.
I'm lost!
- Oh me, yeah.
I've had a lot of that lately.
- So did they get better?
- They did get better.
- Okay.
- Do you think it's because you were like,
these are (beep)?
- Jason was like,
"God, I don't know why they've got better
when you've complained
about them globally."
(Kelly laughs)
- I don't know what's happening there.
- But do you know what?
- There's a link.
- If you add a lot of
butter and a lot of sugar,
you could be eating an old shoe
and it would taste nice.
- Absolutely.
- Just pile on all the lard and the sugar.
- The lard.
- No, they're good.
They're good now.
- So the show inspired
a new ice cream flavor at Jeni's.
It's called "Biscuits with the Boss."
- I haven't tried it yet.
- You haven't?
Okay, we didn't know if you
tried it, so we have some.
I'm gonna try it with you.
I've never tried it either.
- Ooh, ooh!
- It might need more sugar.
- We just need to be watching a movie.
Get some chips and dips.
- I'm down, I'm down.
- Oh my god, I love this.
Look at the packaging.
- Wait, look at your fancy wooden fork.
Only the best at "The
Kelly Clarkson Show."
- Fancy.
- Okay, I'm tasting it.
- [Hannah] Oh, look, there's
a biscuit box on the...
Oh, my gosh.
- Okay.
- [Hannah] Oh, this is perfect timing.
- You know you've made it
when they make a flavor,
is all I'm saying.
- Oh, my god.
This is literally gonna
do my hangover a treat.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Or you'll have an encore later.
- That is so much nicer.
- Than the...
(Kelly laughs)
- [Hannah] That's so much nicer.
- It's interesting 'cause
it's got the biscuit flavor.
I dug in to make sure I had it all.
That's good!
- Look!
Big dirty chunks!
- Yes, it's very shortbread-y.
- Ooh!
(Kelly laughs)
- It's very shortbread-y.
I like it.
- I'm just gonna keep going.
- Go ahead.
I'm just warning you after a hangover,
it might not end well, but anyway...
(Hannah laughs)
- It might come back.
You just co-hosted one of
my favorite shows actually.
I love Eurovision.
- Eurovision!
- Eurovision 2023.
- Oh, my god.
- [Kelly] How was it?
How is it being a part of that show?
- [Hannah] Honestly, just insane.
- [Kelly] You grew up on it?
- Yeah, I totally grew up on it.
I'm from musical theater, for God's sake.
- Because I love Eurovision too,
with Will Ferrell and Rachel.
- But they got that spot-on.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I know!
But that's why I loved it.
- Yeah.
But there's been some amazing guys
that have come out of that.
- Måneskin!
- Måneskin.
- I love Måneskin.
- Oh my god, I love them.
And then back in the
day we had Bucks Fizz.
I mean, which would never happen now.
Like, a four-people group and two girls.
And in one part of the song,
the guys whip the girls' skirts off
and they've got like minis.
And I was like, can you
imagine a woman going,
"Oh no, that's cool."
Now?
- "Yeah, let's do it."
- Oh, my god.
- I know, but I think
that's what's so funny,
Not funny, but just entertaining
is like, how outrageous it can get.
- [Hannah] That's the best part of it.
- Even like Måneskin,
they're outrageous in
the way that they look.
They're, first of all, in
a Vogue shoot all the time.
It's very theatrical,
but like, their attire,
their aesthetic is cool
and the songs are rad.
- Yeah.
- I mean obviously like ABBA, Celine Dion,
there's so many winners from that show
that went on to be musicians.
- I mean, Celine Dion.
- Yeah.
- God, what we would've given
to hear her sing back then with that.
I mean, just incredible.
Yeah, so it's been quite overwhelming.
But I'd never worked
with an in-ear doo-da.
- I hate it.
I am not the person for that.
- You know what's I do?
This....
- Yeah, you go like...
- I look up and I'm just like...
I hate... I literally begged-
- It's like trying
figure out who's farted.
(Kelly laughs)
It's not good.
- It's not good for me either.
I don't do well.
- I have to stop myself going,
sorry, 180 million people.
"What?"
Awful.
- Yeah, I didn't get used to it.
I didn't at all.
And then the crowd gets
so loud and you're like...
It almost sounds like
Charlie Brown's teacher,
"Wah, wah, wah, wah."
And you're like, I don't
understand what you're saying.
And we're on live television.
Anyway, it was a hit.
Okay, so I don't know about you
but I am terrible at words,
like remembering words.
- Rubbish.
- And I write them, but
I still forget them.
- You write them but you still forget.
- Literally, the songs I write, I forget.
- You forget your own words?
- All the time.
- Oh my god, I love this.
- Yeah, I can literally...
It's a talent.
I can be staring at the words
and still sing something different.
I don't know what that means.
- Do you know what that is?
Motherhood.
- Yeah.
And I'm ADHD, so I'm also...
My brain is just always
thinking of a thousand things.
- I'm a little bit like, "Squirrel!"
- Oh, that's literally
what I say, is squirrel.
Okay, so we're so much alike.
So should we play a game
to find out who is worse?
- Yes, let's see how bad I am in a game.
Let's do it.
- Yes, let's do it.
We're gonna go to a break.
The finale of "Ted
Lasso" is tomorrow night
on Apple TV Plus.